okay all right i i don't know how many times i'm gonna be
looping because uh my food's still not here i want my jumbo
nigiri also it can't be too loud because then i'm worried if
i ran too much about my food they're gonna hear me outside
and then they're gonna and then they'll never come back with
my food
so i i'm i'm i don't want to I don't want to be too loud
just in case they hear me outside the door and then they
turn away.
They turn around and never come back.
I'm trying not to be too loud right now.
They won't do that because then you can get refunds.
Yes, but also I just want my jumbo size nigeri.
right now for those who don't know who are not in the
members also a door kid thank you welcome to tomato farm
welcome welcome um i've been crave okay if you guys ever
seen those viral youtube shorts um uh where oh my god
i'll leave your food on the table because too much lineup
and i have other orders
bro Okay, this is fucked up because Do we give him the
that's fucked up
Rate your order Note from my delivery driver Enjoy
No, tell them that I'm gonna wait I'm gonna wait 10 minutes
before I don't want to have to see the review they turn
around and then take the food okay okay it's it's to be fair
i was like because you know how okay for those who don't
know if you click on their profiles they did give a
description why they join they join as an uber eats order um
and like like it tells the i don't know why it does that but
it's their life story on why they're on like as an uber east
delivery driver so i clicked i don't when i found out about
it i like to like click on the profile just to see like a
little glimpse of their lives uh their life you know my uber
driver and this guy it was like why did you join uber eats
yeah the uber lore and then and then his reasoning was my
wife is pregnant i'm like oh man like yeah they have lore
you just click on their profile picture and then you get to
learn lore about your delivery driver and so i'm just like
oh man why did i have to learn your uber eats lore why why
did i have to learn your lore because now now it's your it
is your fault
guilt-tripping more who would look at their Uber Eats lore
only me I would apparently I do not believe that for a
second I me don't care where food he could be lying that's
true he could be lying he could be trying to guilt-trip me
for more tips but who would look at the Uber Eats lore I am
the 1% that actually reads up on what they're doing in their
lives.
Alright, it's downstairs.
You know how like, I live in an apartment complex, so
there's like a table for deliveries and stuff, but I don't
want to go downstairs because it is rush hour right now
where people are coming back, and if for some fucking reason
someone is moving in at 5 to 6 p.m., so there's only two
elevators working right now.
has a lot of floors so so when i was like when i went
downstairs because i wanted to buy get some bubble tea so i
went downstairs oh yeah it's the weekend never mind i still
people are going out and going in uh you are going out and
going in and so i wanted i didn't order a drink because like
i was just like i'm gonna grab uh no you don't understand
there's no way you can i can by the time i'll be down at the
lobby for those who are saying the stairs let me tell you
what about doxing myself there's at least more than 30
floors and let's just say I might be at the upper limit
that's so people are like just use the stairs I, there's a
reason why I don't use the stairs.
I am the, good cardio though.
Girl,
you'll never make it.
Just walk down 30 flights of stairs.
Just that easy.
I'm not even in the, I'm not even at the top, the highest
floor.
Let me tell you that.
I'm, I will tell you guys this.
my floor is not even is barely even the highest floor is it
it's not even close to where the highest floor is all right
just think of it as leg daila molly thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you um i live in a one bedroom of
apartment guys I Anyway, anyway, anyway as I was saying
Where was I at where was I at before I saw so I said just
use the stairs I have to go down to the lobby to pick up my
food So I really want my jumbo nigiri guys.
Oh, yeah, for those who don't know what the jumbo nigiri is
So there's like a YouTube shorts There's like YouTube,
there's like, there's been like viral shorts about, uh, uh,
of these like jump, giant ass nigeri, salmon nigeri sushi's.
And like, uh, finally, there's actually one in my city where
they actually sell them.
I've been seeing a lot of those shorts lately and I've been
craving them.
And I finally found one.
And they're so good.
Oh, my, they're, they are, they're worth it.
They are so worth it.
found out yesterday is from a ghost kitchen but it's i don't
care it's actually one of the um one of the best sushi i've
ever had and i've been to japan too i've been to japan that
that jumbo ass size nigiri fucking slaps and i've been
ordering from them at least once a week because i fucking
love their sushi.
Like, I, oh my god, they're ginormous and they are so good.
Like, it's amazing.
Like, I didn't think a goat, like, I only found it was a
ghost kitchen because I was so good.
I wanted to eat there in person.
Like, that's how good it was.
I was like, oh my god, this place, this place is so good.
I'm gonna go there in person and try it out at the dining
table.
I got there.
It was like, it was like 10 p.m.
or some shit.
I got there.
It was at a laundromat.
I was so confused.
I was like, where the fuck is the sushi place?
And then it was at a fucking laundromat.
And then I was looking around and I saw a sign.
I saw three signs.
And they were all for three different restaurants to pick up
your order.
And I was like, oh my God.
this is a ghost kitchen and i went inside and i was like
hello i would like to place my order
but then they ran out they ran out they just ran out the
giant jumbo size nigiri's so i couldn't even fucking eat my
jumbo nigiri's anyway i'm gonna go pick up my sushi now i'll
be right back guys if anybody's okay let me put up the text
be like um my uber order not to come up so i have to pick it
up oh yeah that's the reason why i hate i don't like it at
this time uh at this time picking up orders is because i
went downstairs to grab a drink because there is a boba tea
place So I just walked over there and to grab it.
And then it took, I had to wait like around eight minutes at
the elevator to get to my floor.
Because one of the elevators is being used for by someone to
move in right now.
Why the fuck at this time?
Usually you move in in the morning.
So the third elevator is out of commission right now.
So I had to wait at the lobby for eight minutes to just for
one.
elevators one of the elevators to be free to be freed and
it's like all of us cramped into the elevator too because
there's so many floors um so i did not want to go down again
because of that anyway i'll be right back guys i'm gonna
grab my sushi i
am back the elevator took so long that there was 14 plus of
us in that elevator
And the worst part, the worst part was that out of those 14
plus people in that elevator, I had to be on the highest
floor out of all 14 of us.
So it was just me waiting at like pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
and then and also i i got that yeah yeah and and oh the
trouble is about it anyway and also also uh might as well
take this stairs oh i cannot wait to eat this oh my god i'm
so excited i've been craving this for two days um and also i
thought i was so fast i was like i got down um i got down
grabbed it and it instantly went to the elevator like it was
like a sub 30 like sub 10 second uh run and and then the
moment i got the elevator was gone the it was it was gone it
was already heading to its next destination um i was like no
Yeah, by the way, the security is so tight where there was
obviously like an elderly couple An elderly couple was like
We're here for the baby shower because like they wanted to
They needed like assistance in getting to like the floor of
whoever is hosting a baby shower And then the lobby was like
nope Yeah, it's like can you take us to this floor?
Because we're heading to a baby shower like the lobby guy
the concierge was like nope y'all call him and pick you up
we can't do anything about it like i was like damn what are
you gonna do fucking break into somebody's apartment oh my
god not even for this elderly couple yeah the guy's he's
like i can't do it dims the rules you gotta y'all call your
call the person pick you up like i was like oh wow all right
Like, can't do it in your butt for you.
You got to wait here in the lobby.
You had no exceptions.
There could be evil grandparents.
That's true.
Oh, my God.
It's so good.
Oh, God.
This is so good.
Sorry.
I've been craving this for them.
the last two days it was worth it but that reminds me to
give that uber guy a thumbs down now that i have my food i
feel more secure more safe to give them a thumbs down for
everything he did to me
where did i put my phone no wait where did i put it do it
wait give me a sec actually don't know where i put my phone
all right let's see oh where is it oh shit give me a sec
guys what the fuck i thought i had my phone here i did leave
it outside
okay okay where is my phone wait i have two phone no no
don't tell me i forgot it downstairs i know i didn't bring
my phone downstairs because i i would have played on my
phone while i waited but i didn't i i just sat there i just
stood there no don't say that no i know i didn't i literally
just stood there there's no way i really i could think about
was the fish actually let me have another bite before i
actually start panicking me
oh that is good though that is good that is so good i'm
sorry guys i I know I should panic a bit more, but that is
some good-ass sushi.
Oh, I found it.
It was, I don't know why, but it was in my tissue box.
All right, let me give him a thumbs down.
Please let me still have the option.
All right, thumbs down, left in the wrong spot, and then...
Batoki, maybe his wife is pregnant.
Gene, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Bro, the guy was like 30 minutes late with my order.
It's one of those Uber drivers that take like too many
orders just to like min-max as much as much as they want
because my estimated time was supposed to arrive at 530.
like it was supposed to arrive at 5 30 because I ordered at
5 and then and then it kept going up like because then he
kept taking like he was like there's some stops ahead
there's some stops behind you so so I was just like what the
fuck okay I can wait and then it was like at 6 and then it
didn't arrive so I was like what's going on and then now he
was like oh it's too many orders and he even replied message
me I was like I have wait so many orders to do and I have so
many orders to Um, so, uh, and the line's too long, so I
left your food at the bottom.
And I'm like, okay.
I'm just, okay.
I'm glad it's just sushi.
I'm glad it's sushi and not something, not like ice cream or
something super hot.
And so I was just like, all right.
all right let me see actually no i'll give you less there
you go historic great historic great though oh very good
those bad in the heat that's true but kanda's going through
its second winter right now thanks global cooling i guess
and not sort of six stars so yeah Canada right now is going
through its second winter it's so cold it's so fucking cold
right now in Canada so um so I don't worry I'm not worrying
too much about the heat at the moment here um oh my gosh
wait I need it I don't know why I closed I took when i'm
eating it i'm gonna open it again all right sorry guys let
me eat a few more bites and then um and then we'll play the
game i shouldn't i should change the screen since i'm it's
just gonna be a black screen but you know the magenta soup
buddy thank you hi dokey it's my birthday today i got case
suggestions from you each year i need suggestion for a sad
birthday case like Before I had McDonald's fish fillet with
a fry as a candle.
Hope you and the dragons have an amazing day.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, all right, guys.
Let's work together on this one.
What would be an even sadder birthday cake than that?
Let's go here for now while I...
Oh, yeah.
Spoiler alert.
whoops was gonna be a surprise but from the member stream we
might have decided what games to play for next and next week
the spoiler alert shake my head turkey dad thank you in the
super chat thank you thank you
i mean tofu a tote maybe a tofu cake maybe it's just tofu
hmm leaking why are the leaks always from her
what's the candle more tofu oh i like that a very soggy
fried i like that who leaked it it was her ah that was good
sushi usually i would have soy sauce and wasabi for these
like it's so good it's so good that i don't even need soy
sauce or wasabi um as like an extra for the sushi that's how
good this is
it's honor man thank you for super chat thank you thank you
you're on second winner That's seven.
Yeah, I'm suffering more than you.
Dork you.
Think of a super chat.
Thank you.
The snow melted where I'm in Ontario right now.
That's crazy.
Now it's melted.
Oh my God.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
give the same thing but this time the fry is cold and
stealth i'm a chicken would be even i don't i i actually
know fish fillet is worse than i'm a chicken um dork you
think of the super chat thank you thank you you're going to
love this game dorky it's literally 1930s doom and it's
gonna be a lot of them yeah i'm really looking forward to
i've been i've been looking forward to this game um since
the trailer was announced because i don't know i'm a sucker
for animated the games are hand animated because I love
animation in general and I love like the different types of
styles and stuff um and so I was I've been looking forward
to and then when I found out that caravan palace is doing
the uh the music for it I was so like you know my
expectations for it was went even higher um because I
fucking love caravan palace I I electric swing is like one
of my favorite genres um and I love their music and I love
like that music video where all the animals other and stuff
that shit was so good um oh yeah and the ign was like too
much cheese puns i was like does it matter this how does
that reduces your enjoyment of the game like if anything
that should immerse you more
honestly i think we lost a lot of credibility regarding your
reviews anyway it doesn't really matter guys thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you it's so cold and because
of you the poor rider won't be eating you evil woman i
suggest half a cabbage at least it's round and as a carrot
again thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all
right thank you the super chat thank you i wish it was cold
in u.s it's so hot for no reason and it's april why is it
hot in april thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you so you have the north and i assume you're more self you
get the actual global warming
but don't worry don't worry i believe when it finally gets
hot it's gonna get really hot shout out to all the cows for
fighting i guess shout out to them gee thank you for the
super chat thing thank you it's nice 18 degrees here and i
was just watering flowers in my yard wearing t-shirt sucks
for the rest of Canada things were super chat thinking thank
you you know what's crazy if you say it's 18 degrees to some
people in America they'd be like that's warm and be like hit
one that's what you think warm is that's so call you know
like when I used to live in Asia um 18 degrees would be what
my air conditioning would be 18 degrees would I remember
that because you know you know when you're said I'm the air
conditioner I would always remember during the summer 18
degrees would be what I try my bed It would be where I,
like, it would be like 16 degrees or 18 would be where I put
my air conditioning on.
I'm safe.
Let's see.
Dork here.
Thank you.
This is my first stream of you, and I hopefully plan on
visiting you at Oshi Uplink.
You're not too far away from where I live.
Thank you, the super chat.
I hope you, I hope you enjoy Oshi Uplink.
I'm super excited.
My event manager was asking what I want to do for my panel,
because it's either, I had like, it was either, like, play
games.
like do like 1v1s with people or like do the regular q a so
i have to figure that out and i want a 1v1 dragoons and like
um apex overwatcher rivals and then like you guys can like
watch the 1v1s and stuff or challenge me or we do a regular
q a so i'm still figuring out what to do for the oh she
uplink stuff i'm supposed to like let her know soon because
it's literally next week
Torque, thank you for the Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Only, thank you for the five gift of ships, thank you, thank
you.
I remember I did that in...
I remember I did the 1v1s before.
I was undefeated.
I don't know if that's going to be the stream this time.
I pinged.
I remember I was like...
I was one of the Asia conventions, and I had like pinged
too.
And I went undefeated in Apex 1v1.
But like, that was also a year ago.
um so i don't know if that's gonna change okay one last bite
and then i'm ready to play the video game
sorry again i originally wanted to eat before stream but my
food got so delayed that i just got it like i guess like 15
to 20 minutes ago
oh yeah so i ordered boba tea because there's a new tea shop
place that opened nearby and i could just walk there like i
know it's like not too far of a walk i was like you know i
should go outside and just grab something to drink because i
didn't order a drink from the uber eats because i was just
like oh i have like a drink place near me anyway so then
they don't get more fees additional fees anyway so a lot of
these like stores like the newer restaurants and the newer
places that open they would have like these ordering
machines now i don't know if you guys know it but you know
it's like those mcdonald's ordering machines where it's just
automatic and everything and you just click your order you
get to see what the or like all the foods and you just click
your order and everything but a lot like not just rick not
mcdonald's but just regular restaurants and red like a kiosk
yeah and so like so that tea place had a kiosk but The thing
is, like, it's a tea place.
It's, like, a boba tea shop.
So, they're just standing there, staring at me, because I
was the only person there.
And it's so awkward.
Like, yes, maybe I could just go up there and ask my order.
But then I wanted to look at what they have.
I don't want to just stare up at the screen at the top, like
the top thing.
I didn't want to stare up at the menu that's, like, all the
way up top.
I just wanted to look at it in front of me.
so um so you know i could i could have i could have just
told them the order but then i also like didn't want to like
fucking like it the text is so tiny i might as well just
look at the kiosk and order it like so and i felt like it'd
be weird if i look like went to the kiosk like tap all the
stuff and then be like i would like to have this please like
after tapping on the kiosk So I'm just like, I'm just at the
kiosk, but the kiosk is in front of them.
Like, you know, it's literally like at the counter.
And then they're just like saddening man emoji just looking
at me while I'm tapping on the kiosk.
I was trying to decide what to drink.
I was just like, oh God.
Can you please turn around?
Like, why are you staring at me?
Like, yeah.
It's not like one person.
It was like three people just standing mad emoji looking at
me, fucking tapping at the kiosk.
I felt so uncomfortable.
Like, please.
I'm just trying.
I just want to wear it to my team.
So I have to never use those things.
I remember a study took a swab of those touch screen.
Every sample have.
go wash my hands
okay let me put this in the fridge now too i don't want like
room temperature sushi the only worst part is just i hate it
when the hot rice hardens up too in the fridge
all right i am back uh let's see uh fiction thank you with
super chat thank you thank you i can't already spent close
to $100, but I can't pass the chance to donate while you're
on a super chat reading spree.
Thank you for the super chat picture.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, yes, the gotcha rate right now is at 100% now.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But yeah, also, no, he's right regarding those types.
They are everywhere.
And well, it's a fun fact.
It's why you have to change your toothbrush couple of months
because uh if you don't very similar situation like patria
said thank you for the super chat thank you thank you yeah
so if you don't change your toothbrush every couple of
months it's actually not very hygienic um because it's also
you know when you flush the toilet not everything leaves the
toilet everything stays in the toilet for those who want to
unless you close the lid while you're flushing that's
fucking weird mr.
broken bond thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
like every time you need a flush you just you just close it
i'm gordon thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
uh mr.
broken bond even super chat thank you thank you how many
would take your phone would you tip back to you'll just
imagine the okay mr.
broken body another fun fact um is this wait let me see is
this what it's called um oh yes another fun fact because
people love using their phones now out in the bathroom um
apparently after now studies have finally shown that uh
people who tend to bring their phone to the bathrooms are
more likely to develop hemorrhoids because they're on the
Too long.
Yes.
So, so, uh, no.
Wait, this is, wait a minute.
This is no longer fun.
Yeah, for sitting too long.
So a little fun fact for everybody to be mindful of, um,
sitting, um, sitting, uh, on the toilet for too long.
scary but you got it's health it's good healthy facts now
it's fun because now you guys know and i'm looking out for
you guys i'm safe
hearing that after it got out of the bathroom while on my
phone wasn't fun hey but you survived you didn't get
hemorrhoids though it's just you're more likely to develop
up hemorrhoids so it hasn't hit you yet and now that you
know it'll never hit you see so fun many thank you the super
chat thank you you survive yeah you survive thank you super
chat thank you thank you oh my god the simon show read my
super chat too yep just read it net first thank you the
super chat thank you the ends of bristles rose yeah that too
there's also that but i think the poop particles was more
important though all right thank you the super chat thank
you thank you not good time to eat my dinner i'm losing my
appetite thank you the super chat thank you thank you Gordon
thank you the super chat thank you thank you jokes on those
nerds i've already had
Gordon I don't think I don't think I don't I don't think
that's as much as a victory as you imagine it to be
Gordon I don't think it's as much as a flex as you want it
to be Gordon
okay alright actual good actual fun good news announcement
but our first guest has been announced for the dokiy dokiy
rewind time for those who don't follow me on twitter our
very first guest is shachi yeah so this is for my concert on
july 4th in la um she is my very my first guest that i
thought of to invite uh when i was coming up with the theme
of the concert um because you know she was obviously like a
perfect choice for um the type of songs that we are singing
and for those who don't know who don't follow my social
media She is singing more than just one song.
She's singing a couple of songs, matter of fact.
So if you guys are looking for it from Versace singing, she
will be participating in my concert.
Yay!
Someone was asking, because I did tweet out that her, she
will be, you know, the whale from Nimi's stream for her
birthday concert, or anniversary concert, sorry, for her
anniversary concert.
It will be, Mimi, let me use her, let me borrow the whale
model for the whale 3D model, but the whale gets a new
outfit on theme, which will be on theme with the concert, so
with the songs that we are singing.
So it'll be a different, basically like the same model, but
like a reskin of it.
slash new outfit so huge shout out thank you Danini for
letting me borrow the whale model for this concert um but
yeah I'm looking forward to it uh like I said we're still
working on streaming tickets um so I know a lot of people I
saw people were like well are there streaming tickets are
there streaming tickets for this um and we're still working
on it but if you want to uh if you tickets are still on
sale.
I mean, just, I mean, it's pinned in the chat, by the way.
It is pinned in the chat, but tickets are still on sale.
You guys want to come check out the concert?
And for the future guest announcements, we will be having
guest announcements every three days.
There will be a new guest announcement for the concert.
So, yay!
I'm super excited for you guys to find out who's next.
Who is next after Sachi?
Oh, I'm so excited.
We both work together.
I'm, like, trying to decide what song to sing together.
So, and I'm just really excited to guys for you guys to hear
it.
Oh, the set list is so fun.
The set list is so cool.
But, yeah, first guest announcement.
Yay!
All right, now, now we can play the game.
All right.
Now that I finished eating and also finished yapping, uh we
can now start we can now start the game all right sound guy
around by the way um will cooler doki be part of the concert
oh my god speaking of cooler doki for those who weren't on
twitch um for those who weren't on twitch um i was in the
nikki 3d concert and i'm so so so happy with how up because
i was very very nervous and scared because i like i said um
i was not what's the word i was like i didn't know what it's
gonna look like or like what it was gonna sound like until
the day of this like until stream day so i was just like oh
my god I was just like, oh, I hope everything will be okay.
And then seeing everyone was like freaking out and was like,
you know, super hyped and really enjoyed all the
performances.
Oh, it made me so happy.
And I'm really thankful too.
So I'm so glad I was, I did not, was not like the worst
singer out of everybody.
I was like, just as good as, well, maybe not just as good
but like i did pretty well i held up my own you know i i i
held out my own because everyone else are also really
talented singers um and really talented performers and then
i'm like who invited this guy here right it's like the the
military guys the swat team with the one clown and I'm the
clown you're like who told you got who asked this guy to
show up I'm like oh I hope I sound okay look at the little
guy anyway thank you guys for the huge support and for
enjoying the concert thank you to Nike as well for the
opportunity I was very surprised when emergency sub but i
was still surprised they asked me to be the emergency sub
you know there's a lot of talented singers out there so um
uh i am still surprised let's see all right give me a sec
uh okay wait
uh oh no kid uh all right never mind everyone sorry i got a
message real quick so i had that i have to answer it uh oh
yeah never mind go ahead sorry i had to answer something
real quick
um okay sorry i'm like i can't multitask anymore too much
work too much work i can't multitask anymore um and i think
again guys i i was like oh my god she's so cool and i was
like wait she is me
yeah all right time to play mouse pi for higher
i'm rare here
we go yeah she's so cool which means i'm so cool because she
is me
all right important legal oh wait is that comic sense all
right oh what a france say oh my god so many oh we we we are
next next just the quarters that looks
What's studio cut, director's cut, vintage cut, custom?
Jesus Christ.
Oh, that's cool.
There's like vinyl, like, as if you're listening to a vinyl.
Motion sensitivity.
See none.
I'm fine.
I don't like head bobbing.
I'm sorry.
I'm not a fan of head bobbing.
I'm going to turn.
All right.
Doesn't really...
I'm going to turn off the head bobbing because I absolutely
am not a fan of that.
I'm planning on getting this game after I'm done finishing
Pragmata.
This game gives me Cuphead vibes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, I, I heard it's like, if you're a fan of Boomer Shooter,
then this is the type of game for you.
Yeah.
I just don't like head bump, but my immersion and just head
bump in real life.
Then it feels like the same.
All right, we'll try head bumping.
I'm going to see what it looks like.
If I don't fuck with it, I'll just turn it off.
But I usually just turn it on or turn it off in general.
Yeah, just bop to it in real life.
Yeah, oh, that's true.
I could be immersive.
You guys want me in black and what?
I could do that.
Let's see.
Oh, that's the chroma key.
That's...
There we go.
Oh, but I don't...
I blend...
Don't I blend too much, though?
I might blend too much to the background.
Uh, Dora cute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Whoa!
Not really.
It's cool.
Now I'm immersed.
Oh, I could give myself an outline.
Actually, I don't know how to do that.
Let me outline OBS plugin.
I might actually have to download a plugin for that.
I don't know.
I don't really know how to do that.
Oh, there it is.
All right.
But bum, but um, but um, but um, but um, but um, that rook
oh wait actually no outline because add wait do i actually
have it oh i do wait ha ha ha ha ha ha ha there we go i do
have it i had it thank you pastoki coming in clutch.
I have a 10.
Oh, I almost closed my OBS.
Black or white?
Actually, let me try it.
Alright, black or white, guys.
Pastoki.
Always knows.
Always has my back.
Black is too neat.
That is true.
Really out.
like black looks better all right we'll go with black then
all right so we'll check everything
oh i love the soundtrack already oh my god wait the sound
okay This soundtrack is actually fire.
Is your motion blur?
Always gotta remember.
I'm fine with screen.
We'll see.
We'll see how I feel about the screen shake and everything.
Fuck,
I love this soundtrack already.
Rookie detective.
No, we'll do detective.
I don't know.
Actually, we're just seeking a secret.
How difficult is Super Sluf, though?
We'll try.
Oh, Detective Peppers.
Oh, Superstar?
Grants up enemy damage?
Okay, we'll see now.
Oh, sorry, I got, I checked up the, where the fuck is the
mouse sensitivity?
Actually, night 16.
There we go.
Now, where did that bastard go?
Oh, I wish it was more, there were more tunny elements to it
for the, um, instead full 3D.
Background?
Props?
Okay, E to read.
Quick and steady.
Hit shift to dash.
What's the cooldown for it?
Okay, that's the cooldown.
My bottom bar.
Hello, I'm trying to read it.
Hello.
Oh, I had to read it here.
Trail went cold.
Press M to use the brush.
It's like a hint coin.
Yeah, look out on anything interesting.
Okay, it's the board.
Probably let the scope prep too much.
I'll bring up overall and then bring up the music.
Let's see.
Aura.
Music to 80.
And then overall.
Let's see.
Alright, let me know if it's better.
Sound guy.
Yes.
Oh, I really do wish it was more 2D stuff than 3D.
Just because I'm a sucker.
I'm a sucker for 2D animation.
Yeah.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I did.
First death.
I did not think there was a little...
I thought there would be a floor.
What happened to the floor?
Who took the floor?
All right.
Need a little press E to chug it.
Where'd I go?
All right.
Tap to browse.
Pick the right tool for your job.
Now there's just one at the heart.
All right.
I'll drink to 100.
As long as nobody shoots me, I should be fine, right?
usually goes.
Ooh, money.
Is there anything else I'm missing?
Oh, that's the that's the bad guy.
Alright, time to use it.
Also the toggle music map was that tweaked already.
Alright, who cares?
Let them get me.
I don't care.
I gotta listen to Carol Man Palace.
Oh, yeah, that's the same.
Just take my ad revenue.
Who cares?
I got a jab.
Oh.
Sorry, I don't know.
I'm not a lock picker.
I just brute force my way.
There we go.
I don't need to pick locks.
I should have read that before I started.
I don't know.
I might have been a good idea.
Uh-oh.
He's just walking around.
Oh, shit.
Wait, he can shoot back.
I keep...
Whoops.
Who were the thought?
They shoot back, guys.
But long, white, and leanings, follow them to complete...
Okay.
I don't know.
I thought I was still in the tutorial area.
I wonder if I can shoot this.
Oh, I can.
Get more money.
Is that it?
Oh, shit.
Whoa!
Okay.
Okay, I will say This is one thing I will say That does fuck
with me Um But everything being black and white And also my
Crosshair being black and white It does It does mess with me
a little No, it's just Me being black and white And also the
crosshair being black and white Just fucks with me just a
little bit Because I would usually make my crosshair a
bright color so I could see it.
Wait for the color update.
Cyber, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No name.
Don't use the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm ready for a super serious neuro experience.
I hope there's a lot of detective work, but no cheese jokes.
It'll take me a while to get used to it, just because like,
for me, me.
When I play FPS games, I do use color to help differentiate.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, I did it.
I turned it on.
Oh, I could not... Oh, my gosh.
I could have just...
I'm gonna grab ammo.
There you go.
Where's my ammo calendar?
Okay, I have 30 bullets.
Okay.
Knock, knock.
Oh, I can break the...
Okay, I mean, I mean, that makes sense.
I don't want to waste it.
Oh, can I open this door?
No.
That makes sense that I can break the glass.
I don't know if it's too high.
Let me turn it down a little bit more.
14.
Oh, F to kick.
I almost forgot about kicking.
That's...
right you're on the wrist i run to what the dream a bright
future ruled by big vice oh you have some hate uh hell oh
it's gambit time oh
fuck you kick me i'll kick you back okay maybe i should have
shot him back whoa oh my god this is bad this is bad Okay,
maybe I need to be higher.
I couldn't tell if it was too low or too high.
I...
Oh my god.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, I am not doing okay right now.
No, no, no!
No!
Drink, drink!
Drink!
Oh my god, he's still here.
I'm trying to aim for a headshots wait is there aim
accelerate there's no way there's aim acceleration I'm just
I'm just getting oh oh no that's just controller okay I'm
just I just can't see black and white right now I think I'm
just I'm just can't see black and white I'm getting dipped
by I'm so used to color I'm so used to looking at color
She's colorblind Okay can I change my crosshair I must be
able to adjust my crosshair Right There is one thing I
definitely am changing though
What if My crosshair is the only thing that has color
Wouldn't that be neat, guys?
Wouldn't that be
Oh my god, it feels a lot better Yeah, I cannot, I'm sorry
guys I can't My immersion Oh, I'm gonna test my luck
Test my luck I got a gamma Come on, something must come up,
Brett.
I got...
Okay, wait.
If I do it all, maybe one of them will win.
Oh!
I...
Alright, you will win eventually, guys.
Alright.
Guys, we have...
Guys, I might be able to win.
Oh, wait.
I got $10.
From where?
Where?
Wait.
Oh, that was so close.
It was so close.
Guys, we can keep winning.
There's a chance.
Never stop.
Guys, we're so close.
Oh, wait, I needed that.
Heal.
Is there any more heels around here?
Because I definitely need it.
There we go.
But I can imagine.
Imagine, though.
Imagine when I do win, guys.
You all dealt me.
But you look so silly when I do win.
You're all gonna look so silly.
What was that?
Oh, yeah, what was that?
Hey, I saved the game.
Now that I remember that F is kick.
Alright, they have to be here.
Oh, can I turn off the little four crosses?
You guys got stamina.
I'll give them that.
Is it possible to turn off the four crosses on my crosshair?
Because I don't...
It does distract me a little bit.
Oh, the four dots around my crosshair.
Because I think it would be a lot more helpful.
Just a little bit.
It's a Paduki, it's cartoony.
Oh, did I not push it up high enough?
Oh, I didn't even push it.
What the fuck am I seeing?
I didn't even push it.
Yeah, four dots.
The crosshair part of my crosshair.
Okay, there you go.
I'm getting used to aiming with the...
The black and white, I'm black and white.
Kick, no.
I go up or down.
Wait, did he go up or down?
Maybe I should have checked if he went up or down.
I'm gonna go up.
Okay.
Oh, I found secret.
Oh, it's a comic book.
They say no one...
crimes story story really starts until somebody drops dead
all right oh wait i'll put a little bit more up a little bit
more the middle one talk about let's see graphics you would
think they We would have a crosshair customization.
All right.
Oh, I thought there would be something there.
I need to use more movement abilities.
Oh my god, he has a gun.
I'll just tank it.
Fuck it.
Money!
safe okay okay there you go what oh is my tail not long
enough oh oh oh there we go i didn't was not paying
attention to the length of my tail.
Hit.
Nice.
Alright, save.
Oh, am I full HP?
Oh, I am.
Stop right there.
Yeah, we need some tail extensions.
I can't hear you just fine, you meddling mouse.
Really?
With the engines and the wind, don't care.
Fair enough.
I'll be there in a blink, alright?
Don't worry!
You're under arrest!
It's the end of the line for you!
Oh my god, didn't reload!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
He's so fast!
Okay, that's fine.
Where is he?
It's fine.
Shit, it's not fine!
It's not fine!
Boom!
Oh my god!
Wait, I have no ammo!
No, what do you mean?
Oh my god, first death.
I was keeping track of my ammo.
Last save?
Oh, this is a boomer.
This is a boomer shooting.
Oh, I figured out the meta.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait a minute.
Okay.
All right, now I know.
Now I know.
There we go.
Get out of here.
I'm learning.
All right, now I know.
I figured out the meta.
The strat.
Oh, it's all coming together now.
I have no ammo.
You mean how you're supposed to play?
I'm so used to unlimited ammo.
What can I say?
Oh, almost got him.
Oh yeah, I forgot that Tori Baker is here.
He's everywhere.
Sonic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You want to move to the left?
Is it left-side doki time?
I don't know.
It might be left-side doki hour.
Some falls don't begin in the sky.
They begin in quiet rooms with friendly voices and fondue
bottles.
Mine started a few weeks back.
The sky was just the exit wound.
I don't even think we had our first cheese jokes yet.
I thought it was everywhere usually she swings by the office
with a lead if it pans out she hears it first simple really
she gets her story I get a few bucks to stockpile cheese and
for a moment mouse bird gets to breathe easy but that day
was different yeah I was promised more cheese eat on site
details later had to be someone big Oh, Fondi!
When they remember their mortal two.
Something with them, a old instinct, baby.
I said, turn back.
Let this one go.
At this case, some more trouble on Earth.
But, well, this story is pretty good, huh?
I know.
If Igen literally gave them a 6 out of 10 means there's too
many cheese chunks, I expect cheese.
I expect cheese every other, every 10 seconds.
How dare they?
They are robbing me of cheese.
All right, left side doki's here.
I think left side doki needs to be more left.
Give me a sec.
I gotta find out the right left side doki.
There's so many.
Okay, nope.
Nope.
so this one there we go there's left side doki all right is
that left enough i'm actually gonna move a little bit more
oh my immersion
so many
All right, there you go.
My immersion!
I might have to move a little bit more.
A little bit more here.
Just so I don't cover stuff up.
All right, there we go.
There we go.
Now I'm left side dokey.
It's only HP.
Yeah, it's only HP.
It's alright.
We don't have to worry about that.
All right.
I gave it since it's too much water.
Hello.
What's this about, Wanda?
Can't trust me a cheesecrumb?
Yeah, cheese!
I can give you more than a crumb, Jack.
I can give you a magician.
A magician?
What, like some wacko waving a stale mozzarella stick in
front of a bunch of bored middle-aged mice?
something like that.
But this one disappeared mid-show.
Oh, that's weird.
Some say it's a kidnapping.
Others.
You know, I figured it might interest you.
It goes by the name Magnificent Bandle.
Or whatever.
Bandle.
As in Steve Bandle?
One and the same.
You know him?
You could say that.
Alright, I'm going in.
Hold your whiskers, Jack.
You're not gonna get past the yellow tape without cred.
Or... Cred?
a pass here a drink it's you in the picture well let's just
say the officer guarding the backstage is uh oh actually
innocent he doesn't judge give it a shot he's very open no
that's nice that's very open-minded of him at this time of
age too like at this time of the year like that's pretty
pretty open of him okay he's just chill like that a lot of
heat for one crime scene anything extra here shut tight very
open-minded guy I just realized you can't dash when you're
jumping and I keep dashing I keep trying to use the dash
when I'm jumping.
It's who it's soup you can.
Hello.
No entry without an ID.
Oh, here you go, officer.
Oh, um, looking great today, Miss Fuller.
Oh, thank you.
Uh-huh.
Plus I got my overall volume a little bit more.
I could sound, God.
Alright.
Told me to.
Up to the little more, sound, guys.
Um.
Oh.
What you gonna open this with rookie your tail tell LT I'm
wrapping things up now how he doesn't know oh money look
it's on the floor and I do not get paid enough to be here
switch all right let's open up everything oh hello Any
clues?
Oh, up here.
E.
Hello, officer.
Oh, damn it's where's that darn key.
Oh, I guess he'll never know where I found it.
Where I found a secret?
How?
How is this a secret?
Here?
That's just the back rooms.
I just...
It's just the back side of the room.
How could this be a secret?
Oh, maybe this.
Okay.
Uh, yeah.
I was just like, I could see it.
Then a screw hit the floor.
Screw shrew?
Could just be a kid.
Now, ain't no kid checks out like this.
Besides, the stash gives him up, but everybody's still a
somebody.
What could the...
I wonder if that was...
Oh, hey, there's your spot there.
Alright.
Small town actress found dead.
One of the recent Mouseberry Herald issues.
Most of it's filled with rather unremarkable articles about
city life.
But curious this piece appears on the last page.
A small town actress informed me assistant to Steve that
magnificent bandel was found dead.
Police ruled out foul play and the case was promptly closed
by the authorities.
Of course.
Nothing happened.
It's just show business.
Move along, Miss Fuller.
Okay.
Got the key to the ear.
Let's get this over with.
All right, any clues?
Nothing ever happens here.
So you kept it after all.
Oh?
What's this?
Old pages are stained with cheese to an unsettling degree.
I assume everything is stained with cheese, though.
So what makes this different from all the other cheeses?
Most of it is Masberg cheese.
General Upper Crest, but one name stands up.
Betty do fiddle, stand-in assistant.
Complete with her home address.
Could be worth a visit.
An address book.
Huh.
Steve had an assistant.
And she lives nearby.
Is she a naturally assistant?
Or was it his second family?
A slick poster proudly displays a grand magnet.
waving a whole stick presumably in front of a cheering crowd
named bandal is highlighted a clear sign of modesty treated
you pretty good uh steve all right that's your real name i
leave the coast is as clear as it's gonna get
bum bum bum i keep trying to scope in amazing bearded man oh
two-headed man I was gonna say there's no he doesn't have no
beard only schmuck skips armor packs grab any and all to
protect yourself oh shit oh shit oh I don't have ammo oh my
god I'm trying to hydrate wait I could I can wait this is
faster.
Wait, the kick punch?
Oh my god, I'm figuring out the meta, guys.
The boom!
I'm metacrafting.
You know, this game came out like one or two weeks ago.
Right in the Guda.
I used them hands.
Yeah.
It's down here.
That means I can go...
Oh wait, that's just...
That's just It's high ground.
Hello.
I'm on high ground now.
Wait, I can charge punch?
Like, oh.
Oh my god, wait, I can charge punches.
He didn't taught me that in punch school?
In the 1920s?
Oh, I thought that I got hit or something.
Shit, there.
In the air.
I'll go this way.
Just want to be sure.
That's right, boom, pow, pow, pow, pow, oh my god, right now
of energy.
Pow, pow, there we go, okay, okay, all right, I'm 11 HP.
Pow, pow, pow, pow.
There we go.
I got him.
Alright.
I'm still alive, though.
Nothing to worry about.
You know why?
Does this game have a stamina bar?
That's true.
My boomer shooters had no stamina bar.
Right in the kisser.
Oh, I don't have a...
Nice.
I got tail extensions.
Alright.
Everything's okay now.
Thank god.
Boomer shooters didn't have dash.
Look.
Okay.
I get to pick and choose.
Hello?
Okay.
Yeah.
Aww.
But there's a hole there.
What do you mean?
The hole is the goal, as they always say.
Hello.
Explosives hit E to pick it up or F to kick it fly?
And shinglers and their explosive barrels.
How do I get there?
Meister.
Oh, this?
Oh, I had to shoot it.
Whoops.
I was a little too close to that.
Dokey.
He said kick it.
So I was like, I can't wait to kick this.
Look, I was very much looking forward to kicking something.
All right.
Ooh, secret.
I don't even know what secret I got.
Oh, more secret.
Alright, there's nothing over here.
Alright, nice.
We got everything.
Schematics.
Oh, or what the?
When can I spend this money?
I have so much money.
Oh, did I not loot the safe?
Oh, I forgot about the safe.
I was just so happy I unlocked it.
I...
I was like, oh my god, guys, look at me go.
Unlock the safe, guys.
I was like, oh my god, look at me go.
I'm so good at cracking saves.
All right, we should be good.
I hear a dog.
Where's that dog?
Where is that dog?
That's right, I got the hard, bro.
You got to do...
Oh, shit!
Okay.
All right.
There we go.
I didn't realize there was this over here.
But I could go to wait.
Wait, what?
How do I unlock that?
Spike him, pop him, and drop him.
I did.
Oh!
That's my bad.
Here we go.
One HP and a dream, buddy.
Yay, I lived.
I lived.
Yippee!
Not even close.
Oh, I knew there was a safe up here.
Can I parkour this?
Oh, I parkour that.
There's a safe right there.
name oh like that okay oh it's time all right nice money
easy being cheesy okay it's downstairs so means I can I can
see it even in black and white I can always smell the
moolah.
Okay, use the F.
Oh, I already know that.
Alright.
Boom!
Got to go that way, which means this could be a secret.
Any secrets over here?
Oh, I knew it.
I knew there was a secret up here.
I gotta get back up there.
Excuse me.
Alright.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Boom!
There you go.
I missed the shed.
There was a shed?
I ain't missing shit.
Get me back up here.
There was another shed.
Oh, there is a shed.
Wait, actually, I'm not going to waste my bullets.
Ha ha, what you got?
All right.
Give me a sec.
Never mind.
Maybe I will use my bullets.
That's more than I thought there'd be.
All right.
And then, fist time.
Boom.
Get knocked out!
Oh, I can use my scroll wheel.
That's fucking right.
You messed with the wrong mouse!
I'm a mouse of this house, buddy.
There's a clue down here, yeah, it is.
Make sure there's nothing I'm missing.
Give me a good left-right!
I don't usually stick my nose in these things, but John kept
pushing.
Said it was no accident, and sure as hell not a suicide.
Turns out, he knew the guy.
Back in the old days.
Kill him so far.
I knew his family since, well, since his true thicket days.
Don't ask.
Bad memories.
Ooh, this story is getting good.
I can't wait to mix, mix, miss the three other secrets, and
I get to the eighth comic strip, and I'm like, what the fuck
just happened?
And then I found out he's on a shootout.
And I'm like, how did I get here?
Oh, I should have saved it.
Wait, is he a bad guy?
It's like that.
Which show was it?
Oh, it's like that.
The one with Homer where he keeps getting, where the guy
keeps following around.
get punched and then he has a heart attack or is that sponge
bob is one or the other i'm he's i'm gonna get you i'm gonna
get i kept like mixed up sponge bob with homer they were
both yellow okay guys they're both yellow
hey watch it excuse me excuse me i'm trying to find an
illegal man
it's been so long since i saw color i couldn't differentiate
one color to the other
anything up here oh look at that poor mouse just trying to
it's just trying to live
She might Just lie down there Oh money Is there a comic
strip there?
No Oh there's a save point though
I will say hard At the moment Not as bad yet But I feel like
it will get worse Very very soon.
Have a feeling.
Oh, why did I...
Boom!
That's right.
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Get out of here.
Oh, shit.
Get out of here!
Alright, I'm gonna grab the HP.
Oh, I have a feeling it's gonna get much, much worse very
soon.
I have a lot of ammo?
That's ammo.
Oh, I guess maximum is 28 bullets.
That's switching.
Yeah, I have a feeling it's gonna get a lot harder.
But I'm figuring out the mechanics more and more as we go
alive.
Oh, you think I just...
There you go.
Really?
That didn't hit him?
There you go.
Get out of here.
Alright, nice.
Whoa.
Kick!
That's it.
Boom!
Get stunned!
That's right!
Get locked in the corner!
Yeah, I'll be 100 HP.
get stun locked anything else here just want to make sure
I'm not missing some secrets all right nice I wonder if I
can upgrade ammo I should be able to oh I knew it whoa whoa
whoa okay that's
right get out of here Oh, I love this combo that I'm doing.
Get out of here.
That's right.
Get sunlots.
I'm gaming here.
Oh, yeah, I can grab the barrels.
I almost forgot about that.
It's just so much fun kicking them, though.
Ben, it's just...
Just the kicking give me such huge serotonin.
I was like, I'm doing it.
Oh, I'm supposed to go here.
Get a good old one-two-kick.
Hey, don't shoot me.
Mike Maple.
Mike Maple is the name.
Yeah, yeah, it smells like the devil's...
The fist, yeah, I can't get ready for my fist to find you.
Now, listen.
I ain't got that much time to talk.
And you got a job to do.
So...
I know you.
I heard some baddies going up.
Oh, he's a snitch.
They should definitely go down.
Snitches around these corners, right?
There's always a little light in the darkness.
Yeah, he's a rat.
Snitches get cheesed.
Oh my god.
There's so many things.
No!
There you go.
There's so many things going on my screen.
I should just started kicking
Yeah, this is the place Now which apartment building What's
your apartment building was it?
Oh It's alright, I got my little magic brush My yellow paint
But it's my white paint Apparently Okay
Oh Oh
Just gotta be sure.
He never could be too careful.
I could just, you know, get rid of the thugs right off the
bat.
I knew it.
I knew they were hitting cash somewhere.
I would go this way.
Oh, fuck?
What will I do for him?
And he doesn't notice the way I dress, the way I curl my
tail to sit off the curves.
The way I work the stage, I do everything she did.
And more, and Steve is still moving some of that minks, and
she ain't even alive anymore.
How do you curl your tail to sit off?
Oh, I guess if the curve, like you use the tail, that's like
a padding to accentuate uh your body at this rate i might
have to do a carousel and head out to the wetlands and see
that was true just a bedtime story i know it's wrong i pay
anything to make steve fall in love
oh my god he's gonna she's gonna go through witchcraft just
for him to fall in love with her i'm surprised she doesn't
even have she has she has his underwear but not here oh it
is here wait what the fuck okay I need to save this before
we yeah before we unpack all of this excuse me Louise lady
you're in peace yeah how are you alive Steve was so good to
me and now she okay I just can't pull myself together well i
mean never mind yeah no ask what happened to who cares about
bando right now we can always find him later uh what
happened to you what you mean what happened well not to
double down on the joke but you look uh you know yes a
little broken up detached well 50 off and i still have to
find a new job this is going nowhere i'm looking for steve
well who wish Yeah, you need me a license to do magic.
That's when you know magic is real.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
No one's gonna hurt you anymore.
All right.
Any clue who'd want Steve, you know, disappeared.
I mean, now you can ask the question.
Are you an ass or a boob guy?
We have choices now.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let me just stop you right there.
now give me the first thing that comes to mind all right go
oh the party not really the best time to celebrate no no the
politicians the the um the big mouse party yes sir he did
rub shoulders with them more than once he did like them
hardy perfume girls and boys but uh but he likes the
politics more just ask the stage designer which stage
designer which one stage designer he tagged along some gigs
for them he's working in the opera mostly you could have
started with that the case stink of crime or cheese i had to
go back to the office and figure out which secret found this
is her kitchen what do you mean secret found oh one of the
recent mouseberry harold issue the one briefly counts.
The history of cheese licking and a surprising evolution
into car racing.
When a number of sponglers begin to dwindle, many form...
It's a secret kitchen.
The furniture I'm excited to go.
So we're legit.
By organizing races through the wetlands and the outskirts
of Mausburg.
There's only one rule.
They had turned left at every opportunity.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't realize your kitchen was a secret oh Steve her very
secret kitchen no one will know no one will ever find
out I saw her life savings before I leave no this job does
not pay as well as you think it does everything she earned
from being an assistant and I was like nope I need it more
than you someone Someone's got to fund these bullets, guys.
Ammo is very, very expensive here.
Oh my.
Um.
Oh, God.
Reload.
I'm okay.
Alright, there was a lot less than I thought.
I just thought I was, like, swarmed by 20 mice.
I thought I was surrounded.
I thought I was last man standing.
I have to go back here.
There's stuff over here.
Never mind, that's an invisible wall.
That's right, exactly.
Who's going to fund my cheese?
Alright, I'm ready to leave.
Back to my office.
When it comes to big shots and celebrities, Rhonda might
have some pointers.
Oh, the brush doesn't come out anymore.
So, what's up, John?
Oh, you know, same old, same old.
Plenty of folks drinking.
Not a whole lot of them paying.
You want a bind or something?
Oh, gods, no.
And I ain't looking for no handout, neither.
They ain't crooks, Jack.
Just broke as hell.
Then why keep serving them cheese?
You know, they'll just slap it on the tab and you will be
waiting forever for the cheddar.
mostly shrews you know and when you're lucky enough to open
a bar you look out for the little it's the it's the guy with
ptsd a little guy has to pay one day right somebody's paying
that's for sure just put it on my tab oh there's wanda Do I
need any safes around here?
Oh, there's a key.
Alright.
Yeah.
What's over here?
A secret found.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, I thought it was a tiny mouse.
I was going to be a...
Look at that tiny mouse.
It's just a little figure of me.
I got collectible gifts.
I wasn't leaving without them.
You can't just do that break into somebody's kitchen and
steal their things Oh, yeah, we're gonna do stop me look I
am the law So Jack did you pick up anything useful?
I found my phone could pop guys not much to go on but I met
Bandel's assistant There's this stage designer see Roland?
Roland who Roland the stage designer Nobody ever remembers
his name, so they just call him the stage designer.
Oh, that's fucked quite the specialist He can make anything
from tiny shrew-sized dioramas to huge catapults hurling
limelights all over the stage.
Well, that's something.
Shame you didn't bring him up sooner.
Could have saved me some time.
And bullets.
Jack, Jack!
Hey, if I'd have known Roland was involved, I'd have told
you.
It's like the movie trailers.
You only shout spoilers after you've seen the movie.
Yeah, well, either way, step one's charting what I've got.
This mess won't organize itself.
all right well i find the stage designer where's my this
thing taking me here oh that's my office wait there must be
a oh there you go this has to be a store must be able to
grab upgrades here well there's ammo all right oh this is
where i buy ammo i feel like i'd find more ammo
comic book.
Uh...
Is this not upgrades?
Power swing.
Speed boost.
Pitch focus.
I can throw balls?
Oh, is this for a side game?
What is this?
Let's collect.
Uh...
In case Tammy's little workshop, over ain't quite finished
yet oh it's an optional card game oh i almost got scammed oh
tammy who's damn gotta whip up a new retro cablama this
spiked e crap breaks like it's on a schedule can't believe
it he almost got me too i need a makeover he almost got me
almost sold me something i can't even use
Is there anything down here?
Oh no, he's just sweeping.
Boys, are you interested in a job?
Oh, lost turtle.
Pretty sure he's dead.
How the fuck do you lose a turtle?
You can't even get far.
Church has told her that the turtle went to a farm upstate
instead of letting that kid.
Letting that kid still hope is where my collectible is all
right if a girl lost a turtle most likely a turtle is not
alive anymore that's like her parents just lying to her
she lost a turtle it's just her parents lying to her it
ain't lost girl oh
I guess that's where you uncover, you do your photos.
Okay, crime wall.
Interview active cases and associate clues.
Clues collecting gameplay will be added to the carousel when
opening the crime wall.
Inside clues are stored in the carousel.
Collect clues and resolve leads.
Keep going to solve your cases.
All right, crime wall time.
All right, there's a stage designer.
You gotta know something.
Okay, navigate the wall.
Inspect the clue to see a deep...
details.
All right.
Toilet, you can't flush.
Water is expensive, you know?
It costs at least 10 cents per flush.
That's practically a thousand dollars if you account for
inflation.
Slick poster proudly displays the grand magus waving a stick
presumably in front of a cheering crowd.
The name Banda is, yeah, 10 cents at this time in age.
You must be flushing in gold!
Stick that here.
Yeah.
Old Patriots are stinging with cheese.
Oh, yeah, I remember that.
Don't just have clues or sign.
A lead may be discovered.
Resolve the lead to figure out where to go next.
I think the lead is just me going to the stage designer.
Yeah.
I thought we've established that already.
Go to the amount.
Osberg Opera.
Oh yeah, I could plug it up.
Oh my god, you're so right.
I could just plug it out with cheese.
Hey, kiddo.
Oh, hey, Jack.
Your engine's humming like a lullaby and what's with a look,
eh?
Did you get roped into another case?
And tell me, tell me.
Not a chance.
Well, nothing special.
But you're right.
This does look like doobie.
I'll catch you later, huh?
I gotta poke around me like yours.
Hey, maybe you could do me a teeny favor.
Could you yeah?
Yeah, take a picture for me I've never been to the opera,
you know Oh, never let a grace mousy.
Oh, she's too low class Trench coat and the whole manly
manly and all the money I've stolen from my clients Red
carpet just one shot at the audience.
It's got to be cool.
Yeah, doobie's first soda
Tammy it's best to stay out of the spotlight pretty please
all right all right one picture for my favorite engineer oh
my god a picture cost like two cents a pick I did not mean
to buy a bullet I wanted to buy a comic book all right go to
an opera tab
there's the opera oh there's steamboat Willie got Drive my
car, too.
Oh, that's cool.
That's how you, like, explore the levels.
To be fair, they did...
Yeah, you're right.
They did leave the money around away.
It was practically begging to be stolen.
Like, right here.
Who leaves the two cents out in the open like that?
That's, like, $500.
Hey, is Roland working tonight?
Roland?
Oh, the stage designer.
Yeah, he's upstairs.
Two and a fat with some extras.
Alright.
Back.
He's out there.
We'll have Fine Roland.
One of the older Mausberg Herald issues.
This one...
Yeah, Fine Earth Keepers.
This one features a lengthy piece of history and possible
future of Shrew Thicket.
A small yet thriving village mostly inhabited by Shrews.
the little rodents are running quite the business they're
also causing quite a stir more and more mice are starting to
wonder they're getting the short end of the stick by
receiving the same pay yes whoa somebody just maybe end up
oh my god there's a little bit of racism in the 1920s say it
ain't so not mine 20s hey thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you who would have
crazy biggest plot twist of my life
segregation between my rodents
the gas
all right well everything needs nice made gone yo this is a
good business for me I steal all the money and then they
hire me to find out who sold all that money They'll never
cameras didn't exist back then, so they'll never know Say
big guy anyway to get upstairs without rubbing shoulders
with the crowd Oh, you want to get in?
Mice and rats living together You game no fuck that Okay, 30
clams If you change him up They won't even know what hit him
Betty's dead?
Hell she was nice so talented i'll never know do you think i
can just walk up oh yeah they wanted a picture is that good
enough photo there we go that should be a good enough photo
the only party here uh
oh shit oh
Got baited.
Unless...
You broke the damn air duct.
Or did I?
I guess you should hire...
I guess you got hired a detective to find out.
Maybe if I go again, I could.
Yeah.
We don't know who did it.
Good thing I'm here to solve this case.
You don't know that.
It could be anyone.
Oh, shit.
Shotgun.
What the fuck did I waste the shelf for?
I mean, it means I could go this way.
Oh, my God.
Let's go.
I'm sure I don't want to waste my...
There's no way he heard that.
Always locked doors and ominous moaning.
Eh.
I think that might have been a little bit...
of an overkill just a little bit oh another boomstick
because
it goes boom more money
okay full hp now i'm pretty sure the fire department frowns
on stuffing firecrackers in the wooden addicts Oh shit Give
me a sec, give me a sec That's right My turn Okay that might
have been a waste I just really wanted to use the dynamite
You don't understand I really wanted to use the dynamite
Okay maybe I can boom this right
It's not Oh.
Wait, you cannot boom this?
You have to aim it.
Yeah, but there's also holes here.
Oh, I assume there...
Oh, no?
Okay.
I thought I meant, like, all holes were boomable.
Oh, there's a stage designer.
Let's save our game and And then...
Let's heal up.
Grab this first.
And then...
Is there anything I'm missing?
Alright!
Alright, now we untie you.
Damn.
Because they always say there's a hole, there's a goal.
What the hell was that for?
Standard procedure.
Little sucker punch before questioning never killed anyone.
What kind of cop are you?
A former one.
Oh.
And a curious one.
where it is oh see that's why i punch before i question
guess i owe you that much but not here those bastards who
locked me up here could come back any second you didn't do
this to yourself wait who did jay nick welcome to tomato
farm welcome welcome up to perform or swipe the costumes and
drag me up here they say anything suspicious i mean
something about preparing for killing stilton during the
intermission and loading a big gun must be some lesser-known
operettas wait wait stilton as in cornelia stone the mayoral
candidate stilton i don't know man i don't keep up with
politics i just finished a 20-hour calibration on the stage
cannon you moron they're no extras and they ain't prepping
for a show there's stilton it's for it they're planning on
assassinating steps.
So much for staying incognito.
They're trying to Abraham Lincoln, the man.
We gotta stop this.
Okay, but how bad are the Mary is, you know?
Yeah.
We gotta stop this right now!
If I shoot him before he, they shoot it.
Guys, just think of it this way.
If I shoot him before they shoot him, Then I take away their
satisfaction.
I take away their power.
Just think of it that way.
But yeah, exactly.
They can't kill him if I kill him first.
There we go.
That's just easier.
That doesn't sound right somehow.
GSD keeps forever.
Stock up.
Hit C to C.
Oh, okay.
Basically got a...
Got my own little healer.
Got a heal item.
I don't need a boomstick.
I gotta save my ammo for mouse PI too.
Don't you know?
Uh.
Oh.
I mean.
Why did that?
Well, I could just... Oh, never mind.
Totally normal, wow.
So true.
The city's buzzing with people.
Just not the kind I'd put on the guest list.
Oh, wait.
Alright.
Alright, I'll do one shot.
Is there any more?
Alright, there we go.
No more.
Back to a fist.
That's right.
Boom!
Oh shit, you came back.
Wait, you just walked past my dynamite?
You can just do that?
Oh shit!
Alright, it's fine.
Everything's fine.
Oh, totally normal.
There we go.
Is that it?
Oh, okay.
There's no reason for me to do that.
Ah.
Hmm.
Alright.
Where are they coming out of?
That's a sniper, right?
There we go.
Easy.
Wait, that's it?
That's fucking it!
Oh my god.
Okay, but did you see that movement, though?
That was pretty good movement right there.
See that little?
See that little...
Whoa!
Also, the shittiest sniper ever.
He should not...
He should not have hired him.
He definitely lied to him.
his resume he was he definitely was not in the war as
someone uh someone that was in the war some stolen valor
shit right there
okay i assume i have to parkour
where the fuck i didn't know that slide castling in the 30s
Why did it tell me to go there?
Alright, this better be...
There's a lever?
It's over there, but how do I get there?
Yeah, but it's all the way up there.
Traffic, oh.
Oh, I froze my...
Whoops.
Bye, armor.
Oh!
fuck you don't understand it's all in black and white you
don't understand I see with color my pattern recognition is
all in color guys okay now I know that's not oh
hello oh my god i forgot this there we go oh my god there's
the sniper
get out of here oh shit
what is he gonna do get out of here i have the high ground
now That's fucking right Doki has white paint It's not the
same guys Okay that makes sense now I was like there's no
way that's it There has to be more to this area There's
seven doors Get cheese exactly Feeling a little stage right
creeping in all right
okay no entry yet oh this feels very boss fighting you right
about now I
don't like this oh there's a piano randomly up here
Reload!
There you go.
I'm gonna grab this, too.
Alright.
I didn't get to use the piano.
Which makes me sad.
So it's alright.
Now I used it.
Okay, is there anything else around here?
No loot left behind.
As they say.
They ran at me so fast, guys.
Oh.
Alright.
Okay.
What the?
Oh, shit.
Why did I do that?
Raiders unit.
But what if...
No, that doesn't seem breakable.
What if...
What if, though...
That could be a fake wall anyway.
second it was not a fake wall oh fuck i do not i'm gonna eat
the cheese my
god he headshot me okay i was i was a little too cocky with
the sniper the sniper i didn't i didn't take him seriously
oh my gosh because there were two snipers oh wait no it was
one sniper hits every shot oh my god
I forgot he TPs I forgot he I was like there's no way he's
gonna get me there
we go I got him
there's another sniper I forgot about him
Oh my god, I already forgot about the other sniper.
There we go.
It's fine.
Alright, everything is okay now.
Did he TP?
I swear to God I saw him faint.
I thought I saw him fucking collapse.
It looked like he fell down.
He had the falling animation.
He fucking baited me.
He faked me out.
actor.
He was such a good actor, guys.
It was crazy.
Oh my god, I have to reload.
There you go.
Where is he?
Oh.
All right, there's a little jump pad here.
All right, He's definitely dead.
I'm getting used to the movement more now.
Those are what are amplating on the hardest difficulty.
Alright, this time.
Oh, come on!
Get this guy out of here.
Oh.
Oh my god, that's not what I wanted.
Oh my god, that's not what I wanted to!
There you go.
I want to kick these.
There might be extra loot.
Okay, I got the piano.
Oh, that was not a piano, but extra loot.
I got to kick everything.
You ever know?
Boom.
That's right.
Get out of here.
Okay.
I'm going to use three bullets.
that's actually wait they give me so much shotgun ammo so i
might as well just commit to it oh why do they let me do
that is there a legally distinct cowboy b-pop
namaste traveler what brings you to this ancient place of
learning it's a basement under a brand new A semantics ain't
gonna get you across that death trap, chief.
It's a shallow pit full of garbage and...
Look, pal, you wanna learn or do you wanna stand there
flapping your gums?
Oh, he's gonna teach me parkour!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, all right.
Enlighten me, maestro.
Now, listen closely.
This here's an ancient technique passed down by a legendary
stunt guru, in new ratterdam changed my life cost me three
ribs but changed my life here's the deal when you jump I
mean it's a good exchange clear your mind no thoughts no
fear no gravity then when you forget your mid-air jump again
works like a charm gotta be the dumbest thing I've ever
heard nah that's dumb work chief the great wheel of infinite
cheddar you just gotta Now get out there and defy physics.
No need to thank me.
Yay!
I did it!
And I didn't have to lose three ribs.
I don't know.
I feel like he got a good exchange, though, out of that.
If you think about it.
Losing three ribs.
Oh, wait.
Wings don't work till you trust the fall.
And I can get you flying.
Yeah, look.
Oh, wait, what?
I hurt me.
Oh, I didn't even see the mini puddle there.
Oh, I fucked up.
No, it jazzed forever!
Oh, my God.
There's no retry.
I was like, oh, I'll just quit it and then come back to it.
How was I supposed to know it's the first one I fucked up
on?
I got scammed out of breaking into somebody's safe.
I can't believe they would do this to me.
To this innocent rat.
And bad ending is over.
I was framed, I tell you.
All I wanted to do was just break into his safe.
That's a good Samantarian.
That's fine.
I just had to inspect your safety Make sure it's up to code,
you know Just usual things Back on track Now with new tricks
Can't dash with my double jump?
No, I cannot Alright, let's shut this thing down Okay, now I
shut Make it nice and useless Alright
Jack Pepper saves the day And somehow start setting Oh
Oh shit There you go, that was so hard.
She's crazy must be some uprooting Oh shit
Yeah, oh my god, what the fuck the boss
act.
Yeah There you go Give my god a war.
Wait, wait, wait, what happened to me?
She, like, transported me out of nowhere.
Like, how did I get there?
Oh, my god.
Excuse me.
How the fuck did I get here?
She, like, kept TPing me.
I didn't even realize I was in the fire.
There we go.
Yeah, I don't think you're living that.
Okay, reload.
Okay.
I was out of bounds!
And I like fucked with me.
I was like, why did it take me there?
Oh, is you okay?
Oh, yeah, nice.
They were...
Well, I'm okay.
Well, he's the framing solid.
All things considered.
See, everyone lived.
It's okay.
Everyone's okay.
The opera.
The opera that cost us $5 is burning down, but like, you
know, it's fine.
It's fine.
But I shouldn't need that ammo unless it gave me more.
the shotgun is actually so strong as we're right oh i should
take a picture you're right i didn't give me the option to
though wait i can come back to it no i can't that's all
right that's all right tammy if you can live for 70 more
years tammy you'll be able to get that picture no i don't
what are we Tammy's just gonna have to try to tank it for 70
more years and then she can see the photo on the internet
I'm I'm betting on the invention of the internet the same
one it's too late I'm already committed wait unless oh Oh.
Oh.
No!
Wait for the bot, Tami.
I've already committed.
Tami will just have to die without seeing the opera.
Alright.
And just reload.
Okay, wait, it was that way.
Aw, I already used, I already opened that safe, though.
Whole story ruined.
Does she have her own quest line, chat?
Does she, okay.
Does she have her own quest line?
If I give her a photo.
Yes!
the things I do for Tammy the things I do for Tammy
well I guess the things I don't do for Tammy so close and
yet no cheese stick a better end for a private leave the
drama for the pros and just give me yeah There we go.
I need to load the map.
Where is it?
Okay, it has to be 829.
Or maybe 837.
Alright.
I just assumed the auto save would still be there for that
area.
It's the thing.
I do for Tammy.
Oh, I hope there's stuff here at least.
Maybe there's a secret.
Oh, no, there was a secret.
That was just me.
That's where I was before.
Alright, here we go again.
Alright, full reload.
in case.
Oh, shit.
Holy shit, he's so fast!
There we go.
I'll grab the heals here real quick.
Alright, I feel like I'm better at weapon swaps now.
Because I'm so used to... I'm used to the mechanics now.
I hope you be okay with things going...
Great game, especially when eating with onion cheese set
there you go they give me so much shotgun ammo compared to
all the other guns i'll say that i didn't have to kill you
but but i'm sending a message right now so close he has no
cheese stick the better end for a private at least the drama
for the pros and just give me the heart they give us super
chatting thank you there we go all right thanks pal I almost
got roasted back there it comes with the territory you step
on stage you get roasted anyway yeah you saved my skin back
there so true so uh yeah so true told you they weren't
extras these were real bad guys with real bad intentions now
about bandel look detective I'd love to help but I don't
know much we mostly just knock back cold ones downtown
besides it's not like he hasn't gone off the grid before not
like this not mid-performance steve doesn't just vanish he
orchestrates it turns it into a spectacle this this is
different i've known him a long time we went through hell
together back in the old world oh wait i used to know steve
the magician jack pepper the trench sweeper i'm touched but
let's not do the highlight Look, you don't know where he is
fine, but you got to know something Where he goes you killed
a bunch of aspiring actors that's show business for you
Daddy's ever brought anyone home from tinsels But when he's
had a few cold fondues He gets into some real fringe
esoteric crap Even mentioned having a lab under his bench
Storming his secrecy on it Secret lab, huh?
A secret lab?
What is he doing down there?
Sorry, detective.
But he's been worryingly private.
Selective about who gets close.
Ratman?
Oh my god, is he ratman?
And bring Steve back.
No way, not that billionaire playboy.
But not a clue where it was.
All right, back home I go.
I got Tammy, the photo.
Oh my god.
Give me a sec.
I have a little bit too much to drink right now.
You know, the 1920s.
A tequila in the morning, scotch for lunch, and a martini
for dinner.
Haven't seen Steve in ages.
No idea where he's been living these days.
Best I just thought I'd lay down the clues.
So?
Did you get me a really glamorous opera pick?
Yeah, but you didn't even cheese too high with a side of
cheese.
What?
Well, there was this assassination attempt and, well,
anyway, here.
Should be enough to draw your own conclusions.
And the best way to deal with a hangover back then is more
alcohol.
What?
Underwhelming, boring, out of place?
Welcome to a hot culture.
No, no, it's just...
what it never mind oh it's the photo not fire as always the
best yeah well always happy to disappoint yeah a hundred
dollars i have upgrades now and i just get dynamite and then
a mouse fruit i must go buy the comic dabble this and that
wash some dough loss some too but it's headed for the big
money something's off jack yeah i'll take this one Yeah, I
take it.
Bills don't pay themselves.
So I went and paid the crime scene a visit.
It was clean.
The kind of clean an uptown mouse noise gets.
After a night snoring bugs at a rot and cheese.
They sure did a good job.
I had a word with the concierge.
Swore up and down and knew not them but the victim.
But boy, did he talk.
damn can't wait to find out what's gonna happen next next
week also be wearing crimson it's like wow but better and
addicting to it they can can can't stop playing it uh all
right think of the super chat thank you thank you extra read
all about it 15 cents what are this paper better be printed
on gold little child Time for a new party.
One of the recent Malasbury Herald issues.
This one has a...
Bro, I'm getting robbed right now.
This is a goddamn scam.
Has a prop...
$15?
That's 10 months' rent!
Of a new political party formed in response to...
Oh my god, it says three cents.
10 months of rent from me like
all these are the ones like Cornelius Silden and his
priority colleague the new group I got robbed in day in
fucking daylight how dare you I worked so hard robbing the
people I work for I worked so hard robbing these innocent
people new group called big mouse party endorses through the
not exclusively mice who are big and strong just like the
name applies the bmp is a rapidly gaining popularity among
younger citizens of massburg cheesy mysteries rule the
headlines these days that kid hustled me real good real good
that's for sure
why he moved out of the basement he finished cleaning this
area
okay Bro, it's like in the shower room.
Alright.
Big mass party members in the opera.
Parasol wants Cornelia still gone permanently.
Yeah, I don't know.
And then, it's just magician.
He has a secret lab tucked under his mansion.
And give the car a proper wash.
I'll be here for a bit.
Corny.
What's he doing here?
He's here.
Oh, hello, Mr. Silton.
Jack!
Good to see you, buddy.
Likewise, Cornelius.
You are in a surprisingly good mood for someone who just
dodged an assassination attempt.
Oh, well.
Comes with the red territory when you're chasing high- I'm
scared.
It's a guy- no, I didn't- no!
If he didn't get- die, that means it never happened.
it was ultimately good for business no kidding how so it was
the extras did y'all hear about that that gunshot quite the
performance as always you put those goons right in the
spotlight and now they're ducking for cover good for me
great for the poles yeah but uh what were you doing there
off script boom gone not just any magician either the
magician steve bandel what steve's gone like a fart in the
wind and now i'm stuck following a trail of stale blue
cheese crumbs i'm most interesting so what did you find not
much so far just running down places you might have stepped
ask me a lot of questions, Mr. Cornelius Silton.
Better yet, I think I know just the one you're after.
Oh, yeah.
Just so happen to know.
Soul searching at that mansion on the outskirts of Mousepin.
This guy sounds guilty.
The address here.
Why, Cornelius, you just made my job a whole lot easier.
Well, you did save my life after all, right?
Yeah, more than once.
Oh, yeah.
all of all of i mean that's that's i mean it's pretty good
all of us were at the war one became a rich politician the
other a rich magician and me a very successful detective
that's for sure uh not a disgrace one one of us one of us
has to be a rat i can feel it one of the three rats Don't
you have the pep places to be?
Something doesn't seem right.
It's like one of three, like in a group of one, three
friends, one of three is potentially a serial killer.
Maybe even a shrew.
That's right.
You can't say that.
Could be you.
Could even be me.
Don't keep that to Ray.
That's us.
I'm gonna call it here, guys.
Oh, I'm a little tired.
I did do two streams.
But I'm having a lot of fun.
This game is actually pretty fun.
I really like the shooting mechanics of it.
I got used to, like, I started getting used to the
mechanics.
of everything um and now you tell like how i got used to
controls and i was like crazy gun swapping and everything
and doing my movement shit after figuring it out but it's
been really really fun can't wait to play more next week but
i'm weeping now i'm tired so i'm gonna go grab some rest and
tell my voice is a little bit dying right now so i'm gonna
go rest my voice and i'm gonna But thank you all for coming
to that stream.
Thank you all for hanging out with me today.
As you guys also didn't know, we just announced our first
guest of my concert.
I'll show the picture again.
Wherever it is.
Where is the picture?
Wait, where is it?
I'll do it here.
I guess we just announced the first guest of the concert.
shachi yeah uh we have a live guest to announce every three
days we're gonna announce a new guest that will be
participating in my oh my god the first time i've seen it's
been so long since i saw color i i was like what is this oh
my god the world exists more than just black and white oh my
god what what is this there's more than two colors in this
world flashbang which craft uh but yes she is our first
guest uh you're heading to la on july 4th i will be
performing a 3d concert there i hope you guys uh for those
who are going i hope you guys enjoy the concert and um all
the very fun songs that we plan for it the band is live by
the way but yes i pin the ticket uh the tickets is pinned in
my chat i can paste it again for those people let me who
might have closed the pin message uh but yes here is the
link you want to go check it out hey guys i'm gonna head off
now as always everybody stay hydrated pause check get up
move around that that blood flowing and you stay up for me
head to bed guys you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys uh bye